20 inflation is forcing families here to
forego meals and businesses to lose
incomes and that's adding to the tension
surrounding this year's elections in
Sierra Leone
has been on the streets for hours trying
to sell our Wares
all day
value of the local currency has
plummeted
the government is under pressure to find
solutions for a faltering economy but
analysts say change won't come quickly
regardless of who wins the presidential
election
unemployment
the economic difficulties the security
issues and people stand on in jobs so
these are issues that any president will
have to contend with and there are
difficult issues
there are fears of violence after the
opposition threatened to disrupt the
polls alleging bias and irregularities
in the voters register
more than 3 million people here in
Sierra Leone have registered to vote in
this election most of them women but
because the campaigns have been marked
by violence and intimidation it's not
clear whether the turnout will be as
high as in the previous election but the
Electoral commission says these
incidents will neither Mark nor stop the
vote
[Music]
it says it isn't living anything to
Charles
we are working with the police the
military and other security sector
members they are supporting us they have
deployed their personnel back on the
streets of the capital Sierra Leone's
younger generation say the country needs
to focus on the future
feels too much you know we are spending
a lot so we are looking forward for
policies from government that are coming
to at least to ease the body on each
student
continue I want to see the continuation
of free education economic empowerment
food security and peace
whoever wins the vote will have the
difficult task of uniting a country
where political divisions have only
deepened over the last few years
addressing the country's economic
challenges will be the key to rebuilding
both Citizen and investor confidence